well brexit represents a victory for one
man perhaps more than any other and
Nigel Farage joins us now live from an
event celebrating brexit in Parliament
Square I know it's very noisy there but
this is as you will know history in the
making we heard you say in that report
no turning back how does it feel for
people like you and the crowds in
Parliament Square now that your dream
has been realized
[Music]
well it's unbelievable I mean you see
the thing is that for all these years
the entire establishment supported
membership in the EU and it was me and a
few others and thousands of people out
there grassroots campaigners who made
this an issue who terrified David
Cameron
into giving a referendum and I've gone
on playing that role ever since I mean
this time last year it looked like
brexit was dead in less than an hour it
happens and I know the right arguments
and debates about what goes on excuse me
the noise is quite now about what goes
on afterwards in terms of trade deals
and fishing but being no doubt at 11
o'clock tonight we passed the point of
no return we're leaving the European
Union we're becoming an independent
country and I could not be happier
was it that bad being part of this club
it's that bad if you lose your democracy
you lose your sovereignty you lose
control get borders you lose control of
your fishing waters you lose the ability
to make your own friends around the rest
of the world yes it's been a terrible 47
year mistake we're writing it today and
I must say and it was a bright very
optimistic feeling about the UK now and
the sea today even Tony Blair saying
look it's happening let's get on with it
make a success of it not look back up
over our shoulders shows you that the
drama is over the war's over we're
coming together and we're gonna become a
normal country again I think it's great
it's your dream obviously but by
goodness it's been disruptive hasn't it
the language is cautioned in political
debate do you accept that the the nation
is scarred by this no I don't the nation
says let's just get on with this they've
been attempts by big business and big
politics to scare the pants off people
they've had enough
they want to get over there and we are
today getting on with it and all the
lies we were told half a million jobs
would go immediately all the negativity
it's over we've made a decision we're
implementing it and we will unite now as
a country and get on with our
independent future and start reaching
out to parts of the world that we
effectively turned our backs on well the
Prime Minister is calling for the
country to be United
there's a light display that we put on
there on the White Cliffs of Dover
and here at Downing Street - but what is
the big sell for you how will you
persuade there are mainly 48% of people
in this country who did not vote for
brexit that this is genuinely a good
idea the vast majority of people who
voted remain now say we're a democratic
country and it's right that we deliver
flexin and I say Peter Mandelson today
Tony Blair they're accepting it
Lord Adonis apparently doesn't even want
to use the new 50p coin he refuses to
have it in his pocket if you don't want
people like him now beginning to look
like members of the Flat Earth Society I
know that your children are blessed with
German passports you never fancied
retiring to southern Spain yourself now
that your job is effectively done Mr
Farage look I have spent 27 years of my
life fighting for this I've given up a
lot to do it and tonight's the night
it's all been worthwhile I believe this
will be better for most Britons better
for our communities better for our
self-respect and our place in the world
I'm proud of what I've done I've been
supported by a huge number of people and
now we have a prime minister saying all
of the right things and I wish Boris
Johnson well if he keeps his promises we
will get a break said liberal brothers
in a completely different place to the
rest of Europe we have
great future ahead of us